TO STAY IN YOUR HOME IF YOU'RE
NOW FACING EVICTION 5 STARTING
AT 4.
WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW THIS IS AWESOME GETAWAY
DRIVER IS A NEW REALITY
COMPETITION SERIES ON
DISCOVERY. IT IS A REAL LIFE
WAY TO DESCRIBE IT IS ACTUALLY
HOSTED BY MICHELLE RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE LIMOVIE FRANCHISE. AND
TONIGHT WE HAVE A LOCAL
CONTESTANT ON THE SHOW.
MICHELLE ABOUT A WELCOME TO
THE SHOW THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS FOR HAVING ME OKAY
FIRST OF HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE GETAWAY DRIVER, IT'S
PRETTY MUCH LIKE A HOT
PURSUIT, YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT
MONEY YOUR CAR YOU'RE TRYING
TO ESCAPE AND HOPEFULLY THEY
DON'T CATCH YOUR TAKE OUT I
EPISODES, YOUR PROFESSIONAL
RACE CAR DRIVER OK, HOW DID
YOU GET ON THE SHOW FIRST OFF
ALL THE ACTUALLY REACHED OUT
MY SOCIAL MEDIA SO IT WAS JUST
RANDOM AND YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE
IS THIS REAL YOU KNOW MEAN AND
IT WAS JUST KIND OF SHUT OFF
FROM THERE.
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE CAR
WITH THIS IS THE CAR ACTUALLY
USE ON THE SHOW TELL ME MORE
ABOUT THE CAR. YES WAS A 2006
OVER TO TOUR BOAT CAR. AND WE
PRETTY MUCH PREP THE OG ARE
RACING IS MY RACE TEAM AND WE
PREP THIS CAR FOR THE SHOW. WE
RAISED IT WHAT HAPPENS WITH
KID FROM SETTLE SOLUTIONS. THE
AND FULL ROLL CAGE INSIDE THAT
WE'VE GOT RICK CARL RECEIPTS
AND A BUNCH OF MISSION A STEP
UNDER THE HOOD WE REALLY SEE
THIS THING OUT SO TONIGHT IS
YOUR EPISODE OF WATCHING THE
FIRST COUPLE EPISODES SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE IN THIS COMPOUND
IS A 60 ACRE COMPOUND YOU GET
YOUR CAR. MICHELLE RODRIGUEZ
DROPS LIKE A COUPLE $1000 AND
SAYS GO YOUR OBJECTIVE IS TO
ESCAPE THE COMPOUND.
HOW DO YOU TRAIN PERSON
LIKE THIS WE HAVE 3 CARS
CHASING AFTER YOU HOW DO YOU
TRAIN FOR THIS WELL I KIND OF
TREATED IT LIKE A RACE IN THE
RACE, YOU CAN'T PREDICT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN YOU JUST KIND
OF HAVE TO REACT TO BE SPARKED
SMART STAY COOL YOU KNOW BE
AND SO PRETTY MUCH JUST RELY
ON YOUR INSTINCTS AND YOUR
REACTION AND THAT'S WHAT I DID
AND I'M FOR YOU GUYS TO SEE IT
TONIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS A TON
OF FUN, IT'S GOING TO BE SO
REAL THEY'RE SMASHING INTO
YOUR CAR THE TRYING TO TAKE
YOU OUT YOU GET REFUNDED FOR
ANY NO NOT AT ALL UNLESS YOU
MAKE IT THROUGH THE GATE
THAT'S ONLY CHANCE YOU GET TO
TAKE ANY MY HOME SO NOW IT'S
KIND OF ON YOU AS A DRIVER NOT
TO MESS UP I INSIDE THE CAR
AND THIS IS A THIS IS JUST A
IS WHAT THIS IS OTHER OK TURBO
SEASON IF YOU WANT STARTED UP
HERE. BUT TELL YOU HAVE SOME
SPECIAL SWITCHES THAT HELPS
YOU OUT OF THE SHOW WHAT THIS
WHICH IS DO I HAVE A GHOST
MODE WHICH IS ON THE ON THE
DASH THERE AND WHEN YOU PUSH
GUZMAN ALL THE BACK LIGHTS ON
YOUR CAR SHUT OFF I CAN'T SEE
YOU.
AND THEN I'VE GOT A FRONT
THAT HAS RALLY LIGHTS AND
DYNAMIC SO THEY LIKE SUPER
BRIGHT.
WE TALKED TO HIM IN THE
BACK TOO BUT I WAS IN THE
LOBBIES ABOUT THAT'S GREAT
YOU'RE BEING CHASED YOU GET
THIS WHICH OFFICE AND HE'S
BRIGHT LIGHTS GO AFTER THE
PERSON THAT'S CHASING YOU AND
ALSO DARK MUGS YOU GUYS DO
COMPETE AT NIGHT AS WELL.
EXACTLY SO THAT WAS THE POINT
WAS TO TRY NIKE.
AND THEN YOU KNOW TO
MISSION OF KEY IN THE
IGNITION. IT REALLY SHOULD
BEGIN.
A OH YEAH,
NOW WE HAVE MICHELLE
RODRIGUEZ FROM BASS AND IF
YOURS IS THE HOST DID YOU
WATCH FAST FURIOUS. I'VE SEEN
THE FIRST AFTER THAT GOT TO
WRAP IT UP TO ABOUT 30 SECONDS
YOU'RE DOING A VIEWING PARTY
TONIGHT WHERE IS THE VIEWING
PARTY THAT TWIN PEAKS ON THE
STAND SO COME DOWN COMING OUT
CHECK THE CAR OUT WILL BE DOWN
THERE SO. IN INSTAGRAM LIVE
ASK QUESTIONS ANSWER QUESTIONS
AFTERWARDS, I'M ON MY
INSTAGRAM LIVE AFTER THAT WHAT
YOU CAN OFFENDER FOLLOW ME ON
INSTAGRAM WE DO FOR THE GRAM
MICHELLE I LOVE THIS YOUR CARS
ALSO LAS VEGAS IS GOING TO BE
ROOTING FOR YOU YOUR UNLV GRAD
WE LOVE THAT YOU'RE FROM LAS
VEGAS, YOU'RE GOING TO
BE WILLING TO GO FAR IN THIS
COMPETITION, THANK YOU SO
MERCEDES AND SEND IT BACK TO
YOU GO TO GET ON THE OTHER
SIDE WILL GET SOME COFFEE OR
SOMETHING RIGHT BACK TO YOU